that damn Film Festival is back guys the
19th annual damn short film festival
will be held in Boulder City at the
Elaine K Smith Center February 16th
through the 20th and Lee Lanier joins us
with all the damn details
in there we love the damn jokes I never
get tired of them I know they're so good
now you're the director of continuity
can you explain no you do it's a title
that shows that I keep track of the
festival over the years and make sure
everything's consistent oh that's
interesting so then how would you say or
how would you describe the continuity of
the of the film festival to now this
year very good we make sure we put a
precedent on really good quality short
films from all over the world and a good
viewing location now this is the first
year you guys are back in person
yeah we were virtual two years now we're
back in person wow so what can people
expect about that experience
it'll be great to be in person again to
press the flash with your fellow film
fans and filmmakers
films are we celebrating what what are
You featuring this year it's all short
films all over the world so but we have
every genre you can think of we have
drama comedy animation sci-fi horror
student filmmaking Nevada filmmaking
documentaries just about everything
that's so cool and how do you get to
become a partner how do you how are you
chosen to be featured in the film
festival well we have a submission
process people can submit through an
online service and we get about a
thousand films a year we pick the 150 or
so best ones that's so great now is it
too late to submit do you like to speak
with this year next year in April okay
okay now um you can also watch the if
you can't make it to the actual Film
Festival you can watch the films on your
website
you have to attend the festival in
person last year's virtual so you could
do that but this year it's all in person
okay but there's a list excuse me
there's a list okay okay yeah you can
look at our full schedule with all the
details online very good and of course
you know this is a film festival but
it's not just about watching films
there's other things you can do there's
meet and greets there's networking
events mixers parties award ceremonies
and it's a great way to meet filmmakers
okay and how can you get tickets online
damn shortfilm.org and right through the
website all right all right here we go
the 19th annual damn short film festival
with uh 153 screenings of short films
over a five-day period February 16th
through the 28th so for more information
again just visit damn shortfilm.org
all right thank you